we are hiring at think media and I am
super fired up because we have seven
positions open and so in this video
we're going to be talking about the
different positions that are open at
think media the details of how to apply
a little bit about our culture and our
values and our mission so if you're
interested in being a part of a
purpose-driven team of creators and
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs that
really want to make a difference in the
world then stick around and definitely
watch this video Until the End so you
don't miss any of the details because if
you do desire to work at think media um
we really care about those details in
terms of applying we want you to have
your best opportunity of making it
through the uh whole process but if
we're just meeting my name is Sean Kel
rhymes with YouTube channel in just a
second I'm going to welcome Melissa from
the think media team she'll tell us a
little bit about the positions and if
you want to skip straight to the website
where you can apply the URL is work
withth
think.com the word work the word with
the word think.com we're also going to
be taking some time to answer your
questions during this live stream and if
you're watching on the replay yeah watch
until the end and you'll get a whole
bunch of details as well and then one
other thing if you could like or share
this post wherever you're watching if
you're noticing some issues with the
tech we're trying some new platforms we
are multi streaming everywhere I think
we're on link in and x and of course
Facebook and YouTube and so uh shout me
out where are you watching from in the
world and I'm super excited to uh dive
into the content here in just a second
but you can jump to workwith think.com
and with that I want to welcome Melissa
to the stream Mel how's it going it's
going great Sean this is always one of
the most exciting things we get to do
here at think media is bring on new team
members so I'm really excited to to be
sharing this with some people who might
be joining us as um full-time members on
the think team so I'm excited to be
talking to you guys today yeah I'm super
fired up and I'm going to talk a little
bit later about um our culture answering
your questions about values or details
that you may have so I'm going to kick
it to Mel here to kind of describe an
overview of the application process as
well as kind of an overview of the
different positions that we're hiring
for but again if you are just jumping on
we do have LinkedIn LinkedIn is working
R thanks for being here um and we got
Atlanta in the house thanks so much for
being here we got California in the
house um and uh we're coming to you from
Las Vegas both Melissa and I we are a
remote company but a few of us are based
here in Vegas and so we do a lot of
stuff remote we also fly the team in a
couple times a year we have another
LinkedIn working I wonder if our Twitter
X platform um could leave a comment and
if that pipes into streamyard as well
and then the way we do questions here is
put four question marks before and after
your question and we'll get to your
questions a little bit later if you have
any questions but good to see you dhn
crypto in the house good to see you
purposefully TV treml tech Troublemaker
Arthur in Denver amazing so fired up to
see LinkedIn in here we got Perth
Australia thanks so much for being here
from around the world okay uh so Melissa
let us know what are the positions and
I'll kick it to you thanks Sean
all right I'm going to be sharing with
you guys the seven different positions
that we have open right now right seven
different positions so some of these
positions we're also looking for
multiple candidates so there are several
different opportunities for you guys to
potentially um join the team and so um
if you head to workwith think.com I know
we are sharing that in the comments
across all platforms this is what you're
going to see you're going to see a
actually first and foremost you'll see a
lovely picture of the think media team
um up here on this page and then we have
some just some qualifications for what
we're looking for generally on our team
we care very very much about the culture
of our team and um we are in every
single one of these positions going to
be very very particular about the kind
of people that we are having um join us
and so um I'm going to talk a little bit
about some of those specifications today
for each of these positions but first
and foremost you can head to workwith
think.com and kind of follow along with
me so you can see all of the available
positions um I'm going to be giving a
general overview on these different
availables um different openings but you
can click in on any one of these and see
a ton of detail on the specific
qualifications we're looking for what
you would be doing in this role um the
competencies and so we put a lot of work
into making sure it's really clear
upfront what we're looking for so that
we can make sure that you're the best
fit for our company and that we're also
a great fit for you and so I'm just
going to start at the top here and walk
through these positions with you first
we are looking for an executive
assistant um to be working with Sean
canel and so again this position all the
spe um specifics are on here but we're
looking for somebody who just really has
a heart to serve who's really big into
all of the details um of of just
managing a crazy calendar Sean is all
over the place he has a ton going on as
you can imagine running this company and
so um we're looking for somebody who is
just again has that heart to serve be
everywhere do all the things pick up a
lot of different tasks and so this
person is very detail oriented can
manage multiple tasks at one time um can
be running multiple projects at one time
and who's ready to just jump in wherever
they're needed and so that position
specifically again an executive
assistant um we would love if you have
um administrative experience in your
past but primarily we are really looking
for somebody who has a um heart for this
company and who wants to be able to
again just help at any level that you're
able to and so next up we'll talk
through our um sales account executive
this position is we're specifically
again looking for people who know our
community well and you want to help our
help out other people who are like you
we're specifically looking for people
who are already a part of our program so
you're already part of video ranking
Academy or V Elite
because we want people who know how
great our programs are and who are
excited to share that with other people
and are excited to bring other people
into that world and so if you are
somebody like that who really um again
is is passionate about what we're doing
here at think then this might be the
right role for you we um are in this
role specifically are looking for
somebody who is a little bit more of a
driver maybe you're competitive You're
motivated by having your sales goals
You're motivated um by wanting to just
you know lean in and push more and work
hard this is um a base salary available
in this role but it will be largely um a
compensation based on your commissions
and so it'll be looking for somebody who
sees the opportunity um that we have
here at think and is ready to um hustle
for it so that's our sales position
specifically now if you are somebody who
again loves our think media Community
you're somebody who is in v in video
ranking academy or VRA Elite and you
just love helping out other people in
that Community one of these three roles
might be great for you if you are um
again somebody who has a heart for
sharing um with other people about VI
rank Academy about the seven R system
you're passionate about those kinds of
things um but maybe you're not
necessarily that driver sales
personality these three roles are I'm
going to be on your radar so customer
success an assistant V coach and our
Facebook moderator
again these three positions are
specifically uh for people who are
currently in our program or you're ready
to really dive in fast into V and start
learning and so our customer success
position is um for people who love
talking to people a lot of you guys are
talking to Logan in our chat right now
maybe you're talking to Brian um we've
got Caleb and Sam we've got all of our
regular customer success employees and
Andy and you see them everywhere you see
them chatting with you in the Facebook
group in emails if you've ever contacted
us at think Medias support.com for any
reason you've heard from one of these
amazing people because they are
absolutely everywhere talking to you
guys all day eight hours a day nine to
five they're talking to our community
members in some form and so if you would
love to be doing that and helping
support people helping get them to the
right place that they need to be helping
solve problems hearing people out when
they have complaints when they have
issues and then helping to to solve
those then this would be a great role
for you if you are somebody who's
actually involved in our VRA Facebook
group you might want to check out our
Facebook moderator position this is the
only position on the site right now that
is actually a part-time position so if
you're saying I would love to get more
involved in think media but I can't
commit to a full-time role right now
then definitely check out the Facebook
moderator position and thirdly that um
role of the assistant V coach this is a
really big one because the v um
assistant coach is going to have the
basically the the strictest requirements
for people that we are going to be
inviting into a position like that um
this is for somebody who is passionate
about YouTube strategy you just live and
breathe YouTube strategy you've worked
on your own channel or maybe you've um
done Channel work for somebody else but
you are very involved in posting videos
you've posted um a significant amount of
your own videos you have over a thousand
subscribers
you've put in the work and really worked
through not only YouTube strategy in
general but specifically the V 7R system
that is our specific system at V that we
teach to thousands of our students and
so that uh system itself is what we are
really interested um in teaching again
through our assistant coaching program
and so if you would like to be an
assistant coach and you say like yeah
that's me I've done this I've tested it
out I've put in the work but you know
what I'd actually really love to be a
part of a team maybe you've given the
solo entrepreneur the solo Creator Road
a try and you've said hey I was good at
it I love it and I got a lot out of it
but again I would love to be a part of a
team be working towards something big
with a group of amazing like-minded
people then the assistant coach role
might be right for you um we are very
excited about that position um
specifically to see the people that are
going to be joining because again we
know that um there are strict
requirements for it you can see them all
on this page but it is um something
that's going to give back so much to our
current um Community being able to um
share your knowledge and help other
people get to where you've been so again
if you click in on this page you'll see
all these competencies here these are
all of the requirements um for this role
so definitely check that out if it's
something interesting to you and finally
we have our thumbnail graphic designer
position and our marketing
Administrative Assistant the the
marketing Administrative Assistant we
are looking for somebody who has
experience in marketing there's a lot of
different ways that you can have
experience in marketing maybe you are a
copywriter maybe you've done social
media marketing um any kind of digital
marketing maybe you're um somebody who's
built out web pages before you've built
funnels um this person would be somebody
who again L loves digital marketing you
might be following um Dan Kennedy
Brendan brashard um Gary ve following
other influencers and other marketers
and you're always curious about what is
the latest in digital marketing um then
that might be the right kind of person
for this job because um this is going to
be a really a support role where you're
going to be touching a lot of different
parts of the marketing at think media a
lot of people might see think media as
this podcast Channel or maybe as our
main YouTube channel over at just think
media um but there's so much that goes
on in the background if any of you guys
have ever joined a web class a challenge
um if you get our emails that's all
being done by our marketing team and so
this Market marketing administrator
would be a part of that team and again
helping support on a lot of different
projects and so if you guys are chatting
with Victoria in the chat right now um
she is somebody who is currently in a
role like that and she just has learned
so much in the last couple of years and
she has become a an amazing marketer
because of her experience on this team
and so if you would like something like
that as well to be have that experience
and to learn and grow very quickly then
this role might be right for you and
finally we have our um thumbnail graphic
design role this role is again another
one that has um requirements of
experience we are looking for highly
skilled um applicants people that have a
lot of experience in um specifically uh
Photoshop and in design and all those
different the whole the whole Adobe
suite I'm I'm not a graphic designer but
we look for people that have that kind
of experience and um we love our canva
designers out there but we are looking
for that level of um you know experience
on those Adobe suits or similar products
and we're looking for somebody who um
again has experience previously in
graphic design in some way so that level
of experience but this role is actually
really special to us because we are not
only looking for somebody who is an
experienced graphic designer but someone
who specifically loves thumbnails and
loves YouTube so you might be a creative
who's also very into strategy you are
you might be also very into trying to
figure out and test what is the best
thumbnail on this video you know what I
want to AB test I want to put out two
very similar versions and see which one
is right maybe if we just change the
background color slightly is that going
to improve our clickthrough rate is that
going to improve our views we're looking
for somebody who really wants to get
into all of that nitty and analyze um
how their graphic designs are impacting
the overall performance of our videos on
our YouTube channels so this kind of
role is again somebody who lives and
breathes YouTube You Love YouTube you
love strategy you have graphic design
experience and you are ready to be a
very critical part in the success of our
two channels this role again very
critical and so um this is going to be a
really exciting position for somebody to
join if you are a Creator who again has
had your own Channel and has had your
own experience creating your thumbnails
then um you might have the right
experience for this role and so that um
role again you can see all the details
at workwith think.com um but that
graphic design role is we know it's a
very very specific kind of person who's
going to fill that um but we believe
that there is uh so many people in our
community who might have the right
experience for that with all of these
roles we are looking for again very
special people um so I might have said
that some certain roles require more
experience than others but really the
number one requirement that we have for
all of these roles is that you just love
think media you love YouTube you love
our mission of helping other people
become um full-time creators so yes this
is our mission um we're on a mission to
help one million purpose-driven people
create a full-time living and a
difference in the world with online
video so that mission we we're looking
for people who are passionate about that
who see how big of an impact video can
have on their local communities on their
family and on really the world as a
whole as we are delivering um just these
purpose-driven messages so if that
mission excites you if it excites you to
be a part of a team of
hardworking um just incredibly
supportive and kind and uplifting and
supportive um team members then this
team is it's right for you it's
incredible so we're looking for people
driven about the message who have the um
you know that desire to be a part of a
team like that who want to support and
help others and who are just passionate
about helping our community I hope you
know um just from being in our community
that we are everything we do is to help
you it's to help you um get better at at
YouTube but also just helping you get
closer to your goals and so we act that
out in everything we do and every day um
again our team members in the chat right
now can tell you that we rally around
that every single day at think media
that's what we're talking about that's
what we're passionate about is you and
your success and so if you are thinking
about applying to one of these positions
then we're hoping that you are also
passionate about the success of others
and you want to do everything you can to
help support that so those are all the
open positions available right now um a
few key Logistics I just want to go over
while we bring Sean up we're going to do
some Q&A so we see your questions in the
chat right now we're going to address
those but just a couple really quick
things U I know one of the the most
common questions you're going to be
asking right now is when do I have to
apply and so we are looking for
applications to be in by October 17th
that gives you seven days to get your
application in now I will tell you Sean
these people like you you want to get
your application in as soon as possible
you really do want to get in the sooner
the better it's going to give you an
edge if we see your application first
and it looks great we're going to get
you into an interview faster we're going
to going to learn about you more and So
the faster you get your applications in
the better off you are um but if you're
watching the replay of this anytime
before October 17th you still have time
to get your application in at workwith
think.com and so that is the deadline um
and then please do give us a couple
weeks to get back to you we will let you
know whether it is a yes or a no um and
moving forward in our um application
process but it will take us at least two
weeks to get through all of the
applications and get back to you so
those are the two quick logistic things
I want to let you guys know when you
have to workwith think.com not only will
you see all the details of all these
different roles you'll see an
application link um that will take you
through our three-step process make sure
you go through all three steps one is
the actual application itself which will
include a video that we request from you
um so you'll need to submit a video
you'll need to submit answers to those
questions and then you'll be taken
through a cognitive and a behavioral
test because we're just you know we've
we've got a really cool process here to
help um make sure that everyone's a
great fit for these roles so so that'll
be your three-step process again
workwith think.com if you want to apply
all right Sean is there anything that I
missed that you want to go through well
number one give it up for Melissa she's
crushing it and so uh and thank you
everybody for being here um your
comments aren't piping into streamyard
but I see Nikki jumping on and shell Nas
Zara over on Instagram um wherever
you're watching this it would mean the
world to us if you smash the heart
button or the like button and then share
this or tag somebody that maybe you
think would be interested um and
possibly applying to work at thank media
um we've been starring some of your
questions if you have a question put
four question marks before and after
couple rapid fire ones um one question
is can you work at think or apply if
you're not in the United States in this
case Melissa um we are specifically
looking for people within the US um
that's for various reasons but one
specifically is we operate on a 9 to-5
PST timeline um if you are on East Coast
time don't worry we've got lots of
people on our team that do um that are
on East Coast time but we are looking
for people who are willing to operate
within those um hours um and then for
other reasons we are also looking for
people specifically just within the US
um if you think that you are a perfect
fit um we do have like the Facebook
moderator role for example um is
something that we could look at um
having people outside of the US but
those details are on the
site um yes and then are they all remote
yes every position is remote um we do re
request that everybody um has the
ability to travel a couple times a year
the couple times a year one of the
really cool things we do here at think
is we're very passionate about um making
sure we have great team Synergy and so
we bring people in for um really fun uh
experiences every a couple times a year
to make sure that we're also just like
syncing as a team getting to see each
other in person so um remote with couple
opport unities to
travel amazing and that's all paid by
the company but yes yeah those all the
travel and in some about 75% of our team
of about 2530 people right now come to
our inperson events there's also the
opportunity to uh join remotely um show
me out where you're watching from if
you're wherever you are watching from
right now I don't know if Kyle meant to
jump on there just a phantom um jumping
on but um and then hey I want to I want
to quickly tell you about the five C's
of think media and then we're going to
answer your question so if you have a
question type your uh question with five
question marks before and after if
you're just joining we are hiring here
at think media seven open positions um
we're a team of about 20 25 people 30
with contractors and everything the
specific positions to that are open
right now are at www workwith think.com
you can go there and see those the
deadline to apply is October oer 17th so
take action quickly if you can smash
like or share out this post with
somebody that's maybe interested um
we're on a mission to help one million
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living while making a difference in the
world with online video we are most
excited about YouTube as you can imagine
I wrote a book YouTube secrets we really
help people crush it with YouTube but of
course extend their message across video
in all platforms plus we have the whole
Tech side of things uh with our YouTube
channel and so uh we really want to make
a big difference in the world uh but
five if you don't have these five things
you shouldn't apply what five things for
Sean well these are the five CES of
think media number one is character this
kind of makes sense though it's the
foundation of all other virtues but
character you know we are we need to be
able to trust you we strive to be people
of Integrity people of our word letting
our yes be yes our no be no of course
without character no relationship or
trust can even work so character is the
foundation the second one 's chemistry
and this is one of the reasons why
Melissa was describing our hiring
process just you might be an amazing
person you just might not be a good fit
with us it's probably our fault too
we're the ones that are weird so are you
a good fit for the think media culture
that's just kind of getting your Vibe
and and you know would you fit here it's
not really even a right or wrong thing
it's just a do we gel we deeply care
about our team and the vibe and uh some
of our core values and things like that
so the second one's chemistry do you do
you gel here then three is competency
are you able to get the job done now
when you go to work with think.com
you'll see that there is different skill
levels for different jobs um we are all
about the development of leaders and the
development of people but for a specific
job you want to come in with some
experience some skill um and definitely
consider can you get the job done as
it's described on workwith think.com
number four is
capacity this is a big one for us
because getting the job done is one
thing in a 2023 and 2024 World it's can
you get the job done fast and handle
pressure capacity so it be one thing you
know as a video editor in my past and
that's one of the things we're hiring
for uh today I'm running the company and
so it's been a while we have other video
editors on the team but I remember I've
been in church Communications I've
worked in different things and I I
remember there'd be like a guy who's
like yeah I can get you you guys
probably a video a week you know working
at a church like a video a week bro we
need like four videos a day and and
that's of course not necessarily an
original video but I need you to like
give me the long form one chop it let's
make it vertical let's get that thing
out like how can we actually go fast and
the truth is about think media is we
deeply care about being built to last
and family and values and resting and
we're not trying to burn out like that
we're not doing that here but when we're
working we're working so can you work
fast can you handle pressure um you know
in certain environments like in the
sales role it's one person's like yeah I
made like 12 phone calls today 12 phone
calls make 200 bro like what do you mean
12 phone calls so there's something
about capacity it's something about like
when we work we work and when we're off
we're off we really like to uh we deeply
value family kids I'm a dad um and uh
and so we we have a lot of parents and
different things of course anyways
capacity and then lastly courage are you
ready to step out on a bold adventure
we're a pretty fast growing company
um we are one of it's on my wall I have
a poster that says move fast and break
things um this we're not a company that
doesn't expect people to make mistakes
like this is the creator economy we are
pioneering and charting new territory
we're going to try experiments not
everything works but can you step out be
bold be courageous um and take a leap as
it pertains to your your job take a leap
as it pertains to being Innovative and
creative in the role um and we we're not
going to be able to reach our mission of
re of impacting a million people helping
them go full-time while making a
difference in the world one of the ways
we define success is when our
community's community flourishes when
our customers customers flourish because
we're an education company so if we can
help not just our customers reach more
people impact more people and do this
full-time but if we can also help them
perpetuate values of personal growth and
faith and making a difference in the
world and being especially in a time
like this where there's so much darkness
and there's so much conflict in the
world so so we're gonna need courage we
got we got to step out we got to take a
risk we got to make a move and so that's
the five C's character chemistry
competency capacity and courage if you
uh like the idea of working at think
media you want to explore the seven
positions that are open work with
think.com is the URL
if you're just jumping on on Instagram
or somewhere you could say that somebody
ask can I watch this later the replay of
this probably the best place to consume
it is on our think media podcast Channel
right now thanks to streamyard we are
live on Facebook and in our group and on
LinkedIn and on Twitter and on X same
place and on YouTube so the replay will
be uh certainly available and it won't
actually probably be up on Instagram so
Instagram thanks for being a part thanks
for smashing those fire emojis I see you
over here thanks so much for uh being
here I appreciate you and uh I'm excited
because Melissa we have a whole bunch of
questions and so I'll kick it to you to
start rapid firing some of these
questions yep I've got some rapid fire
here um van Rod we are looking for
full-time positions in all of these and
so it would really be applying for one
position if you think that you're a
great fit for two different ones you can
submit two different applications but we
are looking again for full-time roles
and people who are going to be fully
dedicated to this one role um Steve Ling
could you talk a little about the sales
role so yes the sales role specifically
is again a remote position and the way
we do things here at think media um
specifically sales we are looking for
people who again want to help our
community and help them move from one
stage to the next and so moving from the
stage of just a Community member
somebody who maybe just watches streams
who watch the podcast episodes into um
somebody who's a part of our V community
and then so on and so we uh look at our
sales position again as a it is a
customer success position the sales team
is actually on our customer success team
because uh this kind of role again is
all about helping our community members
so we don't do super hard sales um we
again are our really our heart is to
help people and I hope that you guys
have that experience with us whenever
you interact with us um but we are
specifically looking for people who do
have experience in sales it is a very
specific kind of person who is great at
sales because it requires being able to
talk to somebody connect with them and
see what they really need and then meet
that need with one of our think media
products and so um if you are somebody
who has that kind of mindset and that
ability to again really connect with
people and get them what they need um
then you might be right for this role
and so um this is a
uh like we mentioned a there is a base
salary but it is very much um commission
driven and so that's part of why we need
somebody in this role who's also excited
about opportunity excited to work hard
and again like hustle towards goals
you're a driver um you might be maybe
you're an neogram 3 you might be a d on
the disc there's different um
personality tests so um that's really
more of the kind of um person we're
looking for as far as Logistics of the
role itself um where you are going to be
communicating with our community members
through text DM email and on the phone
and so you would be uh basically having
conversations with our community members
all day um and then and it would be on
all different platforms so we're looking
for people who are um great at verbal
and written communication so if uh you
have any other specific questions we can
definitely talk through that um but I
can keep I can go through a couple more
a little faster here L we would like but
we love that I love that you applied
we're looking forward to seeing your
application and we'll U be getting back
to you that's awesome I saw a couple
other people that were saying the same
thing um and then we have um Colin
saying thumbnail design yes Colin check
out all the details of this role at
workwith think.com again there's all the
specifics of what that really looks like
um but we're looking for people with
again a high capacity for design and
also YouTube strategy um Sean did you
want to jump in anything um yeah you
know what's also it's funny when you
bring up thumbnail design like and that
one in
particular um and also with video
editing is video editing on the list
Melissa um not on this specific one but
that one's coming soon so editors I know
a couple editors have commented as well
you know there for a lot of the roles
we're hiring we do want you to come in
with experience and when we think about
a YouTube thumbnail designer it's really
different than a graphic designer and
meaning there's of course we would want
you be passionate about YouTube obsessed
with YouTube you study YouTube you
follow five or six or seven X accounts
Twitter accounts that geek out about
thumbnail design about colors about all
that kind of stuff and actually if
you're listening to this right now and
you're like I don't do any of that but
that sounds pretty smart well
then stay up Crush some Red Bulls you
know like you might you see an
opportunity this is your shot you know
shoot your shot but but uh we definitely
are wanting um someone who is obsessed
with the YouTube environment Creator
economy environment and to bring the
context of those skills into it someone
also asked about um I think the pay for
the executive assistant and um and yeah
you could see the pay there the way we
we our philosophy for pay C courageous
living I love the EA and I see it's 18
an hour is that based on market and
experience good question we base our pay
on Nevada our escorp is based in Nevada
um and we base it on shooting for the
median
of that job title in our market and yes
experience would definitely come into
play so if you're seeing something and
you're like man I mean I've been an EA
for you know 10 years and I've been in
this environment and these are the
results I've got and these and who I've
how I've worked for well then shoot your
shot you know apply definitely apply on
the flip side if it's like I got a year
or two of experience and I kind of want
to learn more I want to stretch myself
and and check out this role all of those
things will be considered um when you go
through the hiring process and so good
question but yeah that's where our
philosophy is based we are an escorp
it's a remote positions I know one
question Rd said is it okay to work from
anywhere well it is Us North America us
though um and we uh especially the
Pacific time zone we have current team
members all the way from Hawaii to New
York and Canada technically Mel and so
would be a contract position Facebook
moderator if you're in Canada or even
you know South but ultimately the time
Zone's a big deal and being able to sync
up with us some people you know because
of serving our community and whatnot
there's obviously people get up on the
East Coast all the way to Hawaii we do
some automation globally but yes us but
remote for sure so these are we are a
remote company that does Gather in
person at times we fly our team in we
pay for it um and so it is okay to work
from anywhere but we are based as far as
our company is based based in
Nevada um as an es Corp all right back
to you Mel for more of your questions
yeah um couple quick ones so um you can
apply by going to workwith think.com all
of the positions and applications are
available there and you can see the
hours per week required on there as well
but all of these positions other than
Facebook moderator are full-time
positions so we are looking for people
who are ready to dedicate full-time
hours which brings me into this question
from architectural sheet metal
thanks for being here love having you in
our community um and so do we need to
put our channel on hold to take the
position so I think this a great
question to address and so I will say
and I'm sure Sean will jump in here a
little bit as well um but no most of our
team members actually have their own
channels we are actually really
committed at think media to being what
we call player coaches so people who um
not only teach but we do um we do so
that we can be on top of everything we
can be sharpening our skills and
pursuing Mastery of YouTube and so we
actually really encourage our team to um
maintain those side hustles um with
their own channels of course there are
nuances to all of that um but uh
architectural sheet metal your channel
would we would love for you to continue
that um if you were to come on the team
and so um the only Nuance there is of
course we you is a full-time position
and so we're looking for um people to be
able to dedicate that um you know at
least 40 hours a week to this role and
then also continue their own channel is
awesome and so um I don't think that's
at all a concern and in fact if you're
applying for something like the V
assistant coach we we're definitely
looking for people who already have
their own channel specifically um as a
team we have a whole in our slack
Channel we have something called um like
the think tank and that's actually where
as a team people get to share about
their their individual products uh
projects they do that's like outside of
the company we get to give feedback and
help each other out and so it's a really
cool culture around that Melissa I have
some Instagram specific questions and if
you're on Instagram smash that fire
emoji and even a few hearts and what
other options do you have here the 100
if I could get a couple 100 emojis that
would be meaningful to me um Melissa
somebody's asking what is the video
attachment
for sorry what is the vid oh the video
attachment on every single application
requires a video and there's
instructions on there for what we're
looking for out of that video but so
that we can meet you face to face during
the application process and i'' be my
recommendation to you to follow
instructions closely because follow
instructions closely in all application
process in our culture too someone asked
do I need to leave in Vegas I'm just
jumping on you don't need to live in
Vegas this is these positions are open
for the United States anywhere in the
United States is uh open uh this is
remote uh we do meetings um throughout
the day and whatnot we use zoom
sometimes other tools but we are a
camera on
dialed setup USB mic knowing how to use
technology take our culture seriously
remote company and so um that's also I
mean what's the video for is the fact
that like we recognize that this is
remote but um we are doing our best to
create a a a remote culture where we can
see you you can see us we can connect we
can collaborate we use tools like slack
we use tools like Zoom we use tools like
Monday
and um and then of course we rally in
person as well so video attachment
allows us to uh connect with you in
addition to the other ways of filling
out your application all right back to
you Mel great so this uh Kristen yes
East Coast is is totally fine um we just
asked that everybody is willing to work
on a 9 to-5 UM PST but again depending
on the role itself you might not even
have to work specifically 9 to5 but
that's what we say as a blanket
statement and um yes there are benefits
all of our team members get access to
all of our courses um also courses that
we've purchased as a company so there's
amazing educational benefits um but as a
reminder most of these roles we are
looking for people who are already a
part of V because we are looking for
people who have experience with that
system um it's not necessarily hard and
fast I saw some people asking about the
nuances of that um if you really think
that you are well qualified for the role
and you're not a part of V you can still
apply um but just know that that is
something that we are generally looking
for um I love this question are there
opportunities for growth yes this
company that is one of the most
incredible parts of being a part of this
is like I mentioned I used Victoria as
an example earlier but everyone on our
company has come in at a much lower
level position than they are now and
that's just within a couple of years um
we have Brian who's I think on with you
guys in Instagram comments he came in as
like a social media manager for us a
couple years ago and is now running an
entire department building an entire
department so it is this team and and
the way that Shawn runs this team is so
incredible because it really does um it
put no limit on what you can do if you
are coming into a company like this with
the willingness to work hard to bring
your all to give a lot of ideas to be a
supportive team member to have a great
humble attitude to be a 36 degree leader
if you can bring in all of those five
C's that Sean talked about earlier there
is unlimited opportunity for you now I
will qualify that by saying we are
looking for people who are also
passionate about these specific roles uh
we aren't looking for somebody to come
in and be like well I just want to you
know get get in on this role but really
I want to be like the face of think
media that's I would not recommend that
um we are looking for people who want to
be in these specific roles for at least
two years that's what I always say
be be excited to be in a customer
success position for two years be
excited to be a marketing Administrative
Assistant for two years sure things
might move faster than that you might
move up faster than that but again we're
looking for people who are excited to be
in that position or passionate about it
and who are willing to be in that
position um for a little while because
we are going to put a lot of investment
and training you in that um so that
would be my answer to that there's so
much opportunity here at think and are
just it's only starting we are really
only
starting just a second I want to kick it
back to you to answer Caleb Box's
question it's a good question I'm
curious what your answer is but I do
want to also take just a moment to uh
welcome everybody we are hiring if
you're just jumping on um the stream's
probably only going to go less than 20
more minutes but we are here to answer
your questions but if you want to apply
go to workwith think.com wherever you're
watching this Twitter Instagram LinkedIn
it would mean the world if you hit like
and harded this whatever and then shared
it I mean you could just share it
generally but is there anybody that
you're thinking about that maybe would
be good for one of our seven open
positions um we are hiring an executive
assistant that's for my wife and I a
sales account executive assistant V
coach customer success role a Facebook
moderator in our private group um
marketing Administrative Assistant
working closely with Melissa who is on
here she's our chief marketing officer
and a thumbnail graphic designer pretty
wild because we do so many different
videos and now clips that um it's a
dedicated position that might touch on
other graphic design but would be
specializing in thumbnail graphic design
and so um you can go to workwith
think.com to see all of those positions
if you have a question mark A question
put four questions question marks before
and after the question uh my name is
Sean canell I'm the founder of think
media um the company is co-owned by my
wife and I
founded officially turned into an actual
entity ESC Corp in 2019 um founded under
my Ein as a sole proprietor working with
contractors really
2016 10 years before that the side
Hustle season where I'm building think
media on the side while doing other
things I've been doing video for 20
years YouTube for 16 um and our company
now is about 30 people contractors and
uh W2 employees and we are growing
pretty fast because we're adding seven
new people to the team as you could see
at workwith think.com and we're super
excited about the future and uh one of
the things I wanted to share with you as
well because I mean it's just helpful if
we're thinking about you know
considering working with each other you
might as well know where we stand and
would this be a good fit for you and
this might help you consider that here's
our core values we have seven of them at
think media number one the Bible is our
blueprint number two we are Purpose
Driven
three pursuit of Mastery four big
generosity five love above all six
resilient spirit and seven built to last
briefly the Bible is our blueprint um we
I think the Bible is the greatest
success book ever written of course it's
a lot more than that as a person of
Faith as a Christian it's uh the word of
God the bi that's the book for me on
this rock uh I stand but as we find in
the pages of scripture and the wisdom of
Proverbs in the lifestyle of Jesus um in
the wisdom of the gospels we see how to
treat each other right how to love one
another and even how to resolve conflict
and process issues so we really are
building our company on that blueprint
to Purpose Driven we are we want to help
a million purpose-driven
people so we hope we model that
ourselves and so Purpose Driven for us
means that we really don't just want
views although that's what we help you
know that's important we're not just in
this to make money that's important too
because you need money for the mission
but what's the greater purpose and so
we're on a purpose of impacting people
making a difference in the world and so
we always want to vet all of our
decisions and our activities at the
company are we being purposeful are we
just chasing views are we being
purposeful are we just chasing vanity
metrics pursuit of Mastery higher level
than Excellence we for sure at think
media are a Growth Company lots of
people have come in at different stages
but we're in the pursuit of Mastery
which hint hint is never some place you
can arrive because true Masters always
have a beginning Mo uh mentality shoin
they always have a beginners mentality
so we're lifelong Learners lifelong
leaders we read we study we level up
when we win when we have a successful
event video campaign um we get into the
locker room afterwards if you will and
talk about how we could do better we
review our game tape when we lose and we
review our game tape when we win iron
sharpens iron we are on a pursuit of
Mastery personal growth and always
getting 1% better with every upload we
tell people to do that we we we want to
live the core values first always
getting 1% better in every aspect of our
company internal systems personal
leadership external content our events
big generosity giving is a big thing for
us uh we support 101 kids right now
through Compassion International we do a
thing called Thanksgiving so it's giving
of our money we also want to be generous
with our team we do some profit share
things so it's generous with our team
but we also are generous with content we
hope you experience that big generosity
means we are generous with um free
content we want our free content to be
better than most people's paid stuff and
that's a fact it is we want our podcast
or our channel the amount of value we
give away and so I think that in the
crater economy generosity wins and your
income ends up being correlated to the
amount of value you add to the
marketplace so we work really hard to
give as much value as possible which
also these are connected like if if
personally if I don't keep learning if I
don't keep getting better if I don't
keep improving then I'm not going to
have much value to give if my growth
stops really our company stops our
success on YouTube stops it all stops
and so in order to be generous that does
mean a lot of sacrifice of continuing to
learn of the pain of being uncomfortable
of like oh man my brain hurts I got to
listen another audible I got to take
more notes for sure because we're
constantly getting better so we can be
even more generous love above all we
want to treat people with uh love did we
do it with love you can imagine if
you're familiar with the Bible it talks
about man if we were the best if we
built the best business if we made the
most money if we were the most talented
if we were the most gifted but we didn't
have love man we failed and so it was
important for us to articulate that
value that the way we treat each other
hopefully the tone and the pace love
doesn't mean we're soft there's
something about speaking the truth in
love love is not in contradiction to
truth but when it ultimately at the end
of the day we want our team to feel
loved our community to feel loved our
events to be woven with love resilient
Spirit that's grit we don't give up
means we bounce back when we're knocked
down it means we don't quit it means
we've been through pandemics we've been
through challenges we've been through
negative months p&l people probably like
is it negative now should I even apply
things are going good company's growing
but like no matter yeah through highs
and lows we are wartime leaders uh
resilient spirit and so and then built
to last and that's our culture of uh
thinking about we don't want to just
Chase virality but that's important in
the Creator economy as well like we
don't want to
just uh have a a crazy year where we we
oh wow we had a great year but like we
all died you know what we want to do is
we want to be built to last and so that
does mean we work real hard we we put a
lot when we're working we're focused
we're disciplined we do have high
expectations at think media but we also
have a lot of good PTO benefits and we
have a lot of good we really value
family and we've got different things
for paternity and maternity leave and
we've got um just all these different
aspects uh healthc care is starting in
January for us our team's enrolling
right now and so we're still a startup
being about year seven but these
different aspects of being built to last
saying this and that's based on Matthew
7:24 if anyone who hears these words of
mine and puts them into practice they're
like the wise Builder built his house on
a rock not the fool who built the house
on the sand when the storm came the
person who built their house on the sand
it got knocked down but the person who
built their house on the rock they were
able to weather the storm and so we want
to be a company that's built to last and
at least what we're architecting for in
the way we're building team systems our
decisions is how can we just be in uh in
business in five and 10 and 20 years
still serving people still healthy still
being generous still doing all the other
stuff it's Sim and cynic the infinite
game we're not playing finite games here
we're playing an infinite game it's
Legacy over currency it's built to last
so anyways those are our seven core
values if some of those were like yeah
that sounds awful well then that's good
that's why I wanted to share them with
you because you wouldn't want to apply
here and on the flip side if that kind
of like makes your har heart leap a
little and you thought man that kind of
sounds cool I could Vibe with that
culture or at least I think I might be
able to then uh you could see the core
values on the screen right now all seven
of them workwith think.com I would love
to know your aha moment any takeaways
maybe any questions about those core
values we just have about 10 minutes
left here before we land the plane GNA
let Melissa answer a few more questions
and uh definitely smash the heartfire
100 emoji over on Instagram and let me
kick it back to Melissa
all right um quick question from Sherry
Jones do you have to have your own
equipment or will it be provided
requirements are having a good internet
connection that is primar um because we
are a remote-based company we really
need to make sure that you have solid
internet connection and you would want
um basic equipment to get started but of
course one of our benefits is after a
certain time period that you are on with
us um we do help level up equipment and
everything but you do need to come in
with a basic setup and internet con
ction um we've got this question do you
are there any beginner positions so um I
would say that if you are a absolute
beginner you say you know what I
actually don't have a lot of
qualifications but I really want to get
um to be a part of this team um I would
definitely look at the Facebook
moderator position um that does require
it has its own requirements but it's
something that you could join as maybe
more of a beginner and I'll to say as a
general just for our marketing position
our customer success position if you are
somebody who is very driven is hungry to
learn and hungry to serve and is just
ready to you know soak up all the
information um that you would need and
you are and you hit all of those culture
points and all of those 5 C's and all of
those things are really lined up but
you're like but I haven't had a ton of
experience in customer success that's
okay um that that specific position like
I mentioned um the the marketing
administrator or that customer success
position um might still be right for you
even if you don't have um a lot of
experience and so we just again are
looking for people who are in an awesome
culture fit with us and so check out
more of that page to see if that is um
is that if that is you and so everybody
who might just be jumping on you're
asking um like how do we apply what are
the specifics of the positions um
definitely head to workwith think.com
that is going to be where you apply but
it's also um where where all of the
details are for each one of these
positions um the customer success
position is a full-time um W2 position
for us um the only contractor or
part-time position on the site right now
is our Facebook moderator uh position
and Sean I know you jumped on so you
might have a couple questions you want
to go through and I know you want me to
hit Caleb box too which I can okay cool
yeah and uh I see Justin over on
Instagram I know Instagram doesn't pipe
over here so we can't put your question
on screen but he said I recently moved
to Vegas is there a local office and so
um these are all remote positions we
actually work from home um there's it's
not a requirement that you live in Vegas
however Vegas is a Vibe and so I'm in
Vegas Melissa's in Vegas right now
Kyle's in the back end he's in Vegas
right now um and so there is uh Jordan
is here Omar is here so Vegas and Vegas
is where Grow video live is happening
next April at the M uh Vegas is where
our all team Retreat is this December uh
for about 75% of people that can fly in
for that that are part of the team so um
some of our team is relocating to Vegas
maybe because just purely their own just
they want to live someplace cooler than
they live right now too maybe uh and so
all kinds of different things so yeah
you could you can be anywhere but this
is open to the US um if you live in
Canada I don't know if Melissa agrees
but I think you could at least apply
because it's the right time zone and and
actually the thing is it would be a
contractor position because of so it
would be that position that we had what
was the contractor one um Facebook
moderator Facebook moderator because of
the time zone sync and so uh definitely
hit that one up um azilla one and if
you're interested and so so yeah uh
definitely they are all remote positions
and uh you do have that flexibility let
me kick it back to Mel for a final few
here yeah sorry just speaking of the
Facebook moderator position um yes so
this position is set to a Lim limited
time frame of 60 days um it is a
contractor position it's part-time and
does have that 60 days on it but there
are opportunities to extend beyond that
um so if you are looking at that
position but you want to be on more
committed then there will be those
opportunities so um definitely check out
that position um these are yes we do
have benefits as Sean mentioned um so he
just re he just went through a lot of
benefits so kick back your video like 10
10 minutes five minutes ago um and go
through those but we really we love our
team and we want to just keep adding
even more benefits as we go um tuition
reimbursement certainly I I just the
reason I don't even necessarily touch on
it initially is because it's like I feel
like it's such a small piece of
everything that you're getting inside of
like becoming a part of this team um in
terms of the the grand picture of
everything but um yeah we would we' love
to have you join get access to all the
different products and everything in
there um all right Colin kayb box so um
this is a great question all of these
positions are really big for us I would
say that each one of us uh as our
different departments in the within the
company would say a different position
is like the biggest one we're looking
for because it's the one that we need
but um from my perspective Sean the the
one that I really want to stress is that
V assistant coach because it is such a
particular position we're looking for
very particular kind of person and we
kind of we often call these kind of
people unicorns so um I think that all
of these positions are kind of like
unicorns but this one specifically we're
looking for somebody who again has had
success with their own channel to some
extent but who wants to work on a team
and so who who can absolutely wants to
continue working on their own channel
but is excited also to take a full-time
position on a team like ours and so that
would be that would be my answer because
I just think that that's going to be one
of our most difficult positions to fill
because again there's also so much
weight that we feel and so much
responsibility carried by this position
because um we are hoping that a VRA
assistant coach is somebody who would
graduate into one of our coaches and our
coaches have um they have they have so
much interaction with our community and
do so much leading within our V Elite
community and so um that is a very very
special position to us we're very
careful about any M we would bring on
into a position like that um because
again we care so much about the quality
of our programs so that would be my
answer Sean I don't know if you have a
different one um but if you think that
you're that unicorn definitely apply
because um we we are looking for you and
we're looking for that very very
specific
person great answer I would agree with
that Melissa but at we believe this here
at think media not only are all these um
positions um all the most important uh
without hyperbole or or Being Cheesy uh
every position is super critical here
teamwork truly makes the dream work and
um it is what one of the things I've
realized as I've also been in this
Creator economy for a while as a solo
Creator like many of the people were
helping as someone who literally did
every role um it's wild how far we have
come because of the team and one of the
things that I learned in my journey was
you know when you're building something
I heard John Maxwell put it this way
early in your career you get less credit
than you deserve call it like 2009 to
2015 I'm really hustling by myself and
not getting a lot of encouragement I'm
not getting a lot of credit because
you're not really seeing growth yet I'm
editing I'm shooting I'm discouraged I'm
depressed I'm trying to put the work in
and people don't see that
entrepreneurial beginning hustle
building season and you might be there
but then what happens is it shifts as
the team begins to build and later in
your career you get more credit than you
deserve and now sometimes people are
like dang Sean's killing it no the think
media team is killing it and there is a
lot of incredible smart generous humble
people that are making this thing called
think media work it's not about one
person we really want to build a team
serve people that wants to work in
Synergy it says if you want to go fast
go alone but if you want to go far go
together we're trying to go together
we're trying to build something for all
of our kids all of our families and
maybe you feel it in your heart to apply
and reach out and see if there's a place
that's you fit at this company called
think media I'm GNA land the plane here
Melissa give me a thumbs up in the
background if you're cool and uh and
smash like if you're just jumping on if
you're jumping on just now work withth
think.com we're hiring you could see all
seven positions there if you enjoyed
hanging out today see on Instagram I can
see the heart and the the like laughy
face the crying face give me some tears
of joy and then a little bit of fire and
then the 100 Instagram because I would
love a few more people to see this uh
just in case they maybe want to be aware
that we're hiring and then they can uh
inspect some of the positions if you're
over on Facebook share this out or
whatever thank you LinkedIn for being a
part of uh our our test stream too hey
we're always testing and experimenting
this is our first like Mega stream we've
never really multistream to LinkedIn as
well as to X and it worked and so good
to see you over there Twitter X kind of
it's hard to say what it's it is X but
like you have to call it like X Twitter
how long do you think it'll be before X
will completely take over the vernacular
and no one will remember Twitter they'll
be like what like your kids will be like
Twitter it'll just be like X or or will
we ever make it there I don't know
question of the day is the question of
the day workwith think.com is where you
can apply for the seven positions uh my
name is Sean Channel rhymes with YouTube
channel founder of think media super
grateful that you would even hang out on
the stream like this and be a part of
listening to us and uh definitely reach
out over at workwith think.com apply for
any positions that you're interested in
and we will talk soon